SPACESFIRE MARSHALS ARE STIL
VE RE
IMES MY JOB IS IS
SAYING N LEAD ANON
SENATOR JOHN CORNAN BEIN
HE DISCUSSED WHAT THE BILL
PASS G CRCE TEL BE A FOR
TEXT OF THAT BL IS
SM
DEMOCRATS VE T SIDES
M THILL
NOW.T IS THE HOLDUP ON
GETTIN BILL TO A VOTE?
, RIT
HEREN NALIZE DET  SIN.THEY HAD O
DETAILS.
S AW THAT PRITM OWNING OR PURCHG
ENNS BECAU
S OUAS BEEN TATES WITHOMEONE
OR HAS WITMEONE.AT'S WHY N
TREBOYFD
L THEY'RE STUCK
.IL THEY'RE STUCK O
NA
LUNIVE STATES.
INNA
INTERVENTIONROSO
HO STICKNG BEING DET THEY'RE
STLA, WHATT? H NEXT?
>> THE SENORIZE
THISU
WH THE  CCK TO NAD GET A BILL O
THEXT WEEKR RECESS FOR WEE TRYI
POINTSENR THEY'LL  ABL
E PLAN THE WBAO CONT T
ATNS.
CHRISTI, YOU.
CHIEFHE'S T VAIL,LO IONAL  OA
LETTE
FOTUAY I TO ACT ON GUN
W?>> BORIS, RST, MY HEART GOES
OUT TO TILIA FIRE DEPAR ANUTOM A
IECP,
E HASNN
VIOLENCE IN THE LAST0 YEARS.T TR
IASMALCI
FROM GUNE WHETHER FR E
GAATED O E.
'STHIN GOT
TO BE DONE.
>> A JUS
STICKIN
UDINCENTIVES FOR
T LOOPHOLE ARIEND IS.
THINK WOULBET  WHBILL CURRENT T
BE SNEO
MEASURES. G A NUMBEOF
TH  OSEE IF
F ASSAD OR YOUR SP
ITATION.WHY WOD TILLUR
WE HAVSTEMR TI AREAS T WORKED  O
T FROM
PEOPHAR  C BOYFRIEND LOOPHOLE IG
L
LESSIHOOD OFKIDSHE VIOLE
YOY THAT'S
VEL OF VIOLENCE THAT
N ST VIOLENC
WHETHER OR NHAVER CONVICTION FO
OL OA AND SOIMPORTBEFOREEONEN.
OFPEOK TIME  THERE W
TO DE BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
NOW THEIANTANETHE  COOL THMOEF,R
HE AFED REANSH COTIERICANS AVWEB
COTHERE ARE
AND TAKE ON
E ABSOLUTE AND THE LEVEL OF GU S
THCTIOG ABT DEHS
TAKEN TO START CLOSINGARE ALLOWG
DAY.IS OR VI
L IT TAKESROBLEM BUT ALSO NE
AINRS CANH  O'S E REFERR
YOUR ND?
>> AS THE ENT OF THE IEFS OWE
MY TRAVELS THIS'VE BEENSK OOT G
YO
I'M AT A LOSS TOHONEST
YOU.
S AISSUE BUT  REAABSAFETYOUR
AKSO TI'Y PEERS
AUSTLI HE  GUN VIOLENCN FE. UNO
FRUSTRATEWAA LACKF OM NATIONAL
R I FEICF GUAMILY.
TS PRAYE, ING IT
ANY  A
HAVE GOOECTIVE IN
REO EASIEDACRO L